[Music]
[Applause]
let's bring in kyle brandt the co-host
of good morning football and nfl network
your first jersey you ever bought was
who
i had a chicago bears matt suey jersey
now that's a deep cut dan matt sui was
number 26 he was walter payton's full
back in the mid 80s super bowl champion
bears and i liked him because he had a
neck roll and a mustache and that's all
i needed number 26 penn state
i think it's penn state yes i should
know that but back then i did i i was
six so i didn't even know what a college
was i just know what a mustache was
because magnum pi had one and i knew met
so he did too
all right your mvp this year caught me
by surprise yeah uh reveal
your mvp pick and your rationale the
quarterback won for the baltimore ravens
lamar jackson um you know dan we're
pressed for mvp pick super picks like
everybody and i sat around thinking
about there's so many good quarterbacks
there's so many talented quarterbacks
it sometimes just boils down to the
story for me and i think lamar's changed
over the last couple of weeks you have
the proverbial front runner everyone
wants to hand it to josh allen and
that's great maybe it'll win mahomes
always in the mix but lamar's already
got this thing where
okay so jk dobbs is going to be a huge
part of that offense goes down then they
lose another running back goes down and
it's like all right well then count the
ravens out lamar's having this moment
where he's gonna have to do it all
himself and i reached deep into the bag
and made the john mcclane comparison and
the die hard poster came out and said
one building one cop 12 bad guys that's
just the way john mcclane likes it and i
feel like lamar has the fire hose
wrapped around his waist against the afc
north which again is supposed to go to
baker and old ben and lamar's like well
i guess i'll have to rush for 1400 yards
this year and i think he will
i i don't know i think some defenses are
going to probably shoot the gloss
when it comes to lamar jackson um your
super bowl pick
my super bowl pick uh will go to western
new york the buffalo bills and um you
know dan there's a million reasons i
like the football if josh allen is
everybody's on that rocket and the pass
rush is better on and on but
i grew up in chicago in the early 90s
and late 80s and i really believe i feel
like i was classically trained on teams
to get their nose bloodied and then get
over the bully yeah i never thought that
the bulls were going to beat isaiah and
tucked daily in those teams i was when i
was in fifth grade i thought the pistons
are too good and in this situation i
think the josh allen and the bills are
jordan and the bulls and i think that
the chiefs and the ravens there but most
of the chiefs are the bad boy pistons
and just what i saw last year title game
outmatched overdone um best bet football
still to play for josh allen i think
they're gonna get over the hump and i
think it's wild we're gonna be
celebrating a buffalo bill super bowl
it's nuts who were they playing
the packers the packers who uh i guess
also kind of a jordan comparison the
packers are you know it's the last dance
this thing's going to be broken up they
have the kraus situation where it's not
coming all back and the packers to me i
have very distinctive vibes to
seniors in high school and this is the
best it's ever going to get and they
know it and they know that some of them
are going to go to this college and that
college and some are going to go right
into work and they're looking around and
they all say like let's just have so
much fun this year and drink so many of
our parents beers and listen to so much
rock music and i think they're really
tight because the one thing you never
heard during all the drama and all the
summer
no one takes shots at rogers i really
think that those players love him
respect him and are gonna go to war for
him this year i just think they're gonna
be enough to beat buffalo
the least interesting team this year
the least interesting team by far well
right now it's the chicago bears because
they're playing the second best
quarterback on their roster and they're
gonna debut him on sunday night football
on a national television and it could
get interesting but um if matt and aggie
just does the thing where he says i
don't care folks
i'm going to play this guy all year and
i'm going to preserve this justin fields
thing that's unbelievably tedious worse
than uninteresting yeah but the thing i
i don't understand about that logic is
matt nagy to save his job
needs justin fields
if he stays with andy dalton he doesn't
keep his job because they'll move on and
somebody else will go i can't wait to
take over this team with justin fields
it's crazy you would think if you were
going to go down you'd want to go down
with the best athlete but he has
unbelievably measured matt and aggie dan
can i give you um i have it will you
indulge me an analogy for the matt
maggie justin field situation
and it's it's perfect for chicago
right now uh bears fans are craving a
quarterback they have been for 103 years
and justin fields is this beautiful
piping hot slice of pizza that's been
put in front of them and they just want
to eat it so badly they can't wait but
they know because they're smart that if
they jump into the justin fields pizza
now there's a really good chance it
might burn the ever living hell out the
inside of their mouth because they've
been burned before meanwhile they also
ordered a caesar salad they didn't even
know why they did it they just did it to
satisfy the minimum order that caesar
salad is andy dalton so they're going to
go to the caesar they're going to take a
few bites and it's pretty good it's fine
it's a caesar salad we've had a million
there's a lot like him oh this is all
right this is all right and finally like
enough with the caesar in the meantime
while you've been eating the caesar the
pizza's cooled off a little bit it's
still hot but it's not problem hot the
caesar walked so the pizza could run
that's how matt naggy believes it he's
like we're going to eat this caesar i
don't care what anybody says we'll get
to the pizza when we get to it bears
fans are saying we've had a lot of
crappy caesar give us the pizza now
we'll take our chances that's where i
think this thing goes how did we come up
with the expression salad days
like don't you want salad days mclovin
in in your
well i
brandt went to ivy league school too
it's not like i need to go to dartmouth
here yeah but he only got him for sports
i i was like oh that's true that's right
okay there's no scholarship today
okay the salad days that's what you want
you want the caesar salad days paulie
what do the salad days mean should we
let them guess and see who's a smarter
ivy league all right ivys all right let
me start with brent all right all right
so the salad is i understand the
expression uh it's the good times it's
the you know everyone's popping
champagne after depression and then when
you say the salad days are over it's
crappy and harder now which i don't
really understand necessarily because it
should be the prime rib days or the
pheasant under glass days salad days but
maybe back in the day dan here's my last
maybe uh fresh produce and the things
that go into a salad were considered
prestige items that weren't as easy to
get your hands on so that's my
definition what do you got okay that's
princeton now let's go to dartmouth okay
so salad days what makes for a good
salad fresh produce it celebrates which
comes out in the end of summer which is
the best time of year so it celebrates
summer it's really a seasonal thing like
you know at old times how all the
holidays were around harvest that's what
salads is all right let's go to paulie
pauline i would say they're both equally
wrong the phrase was coined
by
shakespeare and anthony cleopatra in
1906
my salad days when i was green in
judgment cold and blood uh they said
it's a period of youthful and experience
and indiscretion and exuberance it's
about being young and wild
okay wow had nothing to do with produce
wow
sally sat2 is all over again
that's why ivy league is overrated
uh we're talking to kyle brandt co-host
of good morning football on nfl network
i want you to judge our hot takes that
we just had oh please i love this okay
they each have one now you as you're a
purveyor of hot takes like you're
exactly you're required to have a hot
take on good morning football right yeah
emmy nominated show as you know that
yeah
and we were too
yes yeah just nominated uh pauline
paulie give uh give kyle your hot ticket
the green bay packers will start out the
season
16-0
uh i'm gonna say that is like uh
uh mild paprika none of the ghost
peppers none of that type of thing like
it's it's it's a my it's a six a five
sixteen and oh the packers are that good
and that talented they might i i don't
think it's terribly spicy i think you
guys could do better okay let's go to
mclovin okay the houston texans will not
have the number one pick in the draft it
will be the cincinnati bengals oh now
we're talking now we're talking all
right that is one of those things i once
read there's a pepper so spicy that they
rub it on elephant enclosures in the zoo
so the elephants won't go near it that's
getting close to that because
i mean look the bengals got some good
players and maybe they'll bangle this up
they usually do but houston is is one of
the strangest teams of football i have
ever seen on any level including peewee
and i think right now they are already
looking at quarterbacks and not their
own all right satan you i want to give
kyle your hot tip wait can we just real
quick back up are we shakespeare
suggesting that salad has been consumed
since like 50 bc
well not 50 bc it's 1600 well no that
would have been anthony and anthony and
cleopatra would have been bc and that's
where they refer to salad days no yes we
clothing but it's like the play hamilton
like you update he updated old times
with current references because salad
was the thing that i want to eat
exactly
don't make fun of hamilton i saw it with
the original cast twice twice uh okay
you're hot tom brady will throw more
interceptions this season than in any
other season in his career 15 or more
i'm just thinking about hamilton and
salad is the olive garden the room where
it happens i don't know um yes uh tom
brady uh will not will not throw those
uh interceptions 15 interceptions this
year no like i listen i don't think the
bucks are all they're cracked up to be i
really don't we somehow in the off
season because they had a good playoff
run we convinced ourselves that they're
some sort of unbeatable godzilla of the
team because they brought back all 22
starters those same 22 starters were
seven and five lost to the nick foles
bears lost to jared goff got crushed by
drew brees almost retiring that's that
playoff run
taylor heineke gave him the business uh
they got they pulled their mvp off the
field with a chance to beat the bucks
and then they beat a wounded animal in
the super bowl i don't think they're
omnipotent but brady's not throwing 15
picks no way well keep in mind there's
17 games this year there are yeah factor
that in all right fritzy your hot take
the jaguars got off to a very
disappointing slow start trevor lawrence
gets frustrated even more so urban meyer
gets so frustrated that enter cj
beathard week five at home against the
titans it's time to sit trevor for a
little while the legend that's a
legendary take the urban meyer i mean
that's what we're talking about that
show hot ones is great and there's that
scene where stringer bell it's like a
gif where he's choking on the wings
that's where i met with that um i feel
like urban meyer like risked so much
so much not only with his career and his
legacy but even maybe his health and he
risked it all to coach that beautiful
blond-haired football jesus from clemson
named trevor lawrence and from his cold
dead hands god willing i hope i'm not
right you take trevor lawrence not a
chance uh it's the 40th anniversary of
the frogger video game and peacock our
streaming partners uh peacock original
frogger uh will drop the first three
episodes today then drop weekly episodes
on thing okay explain what is going to
happen with frogger on peacock
it's incredible it's like imagine the
video game again 30 40 years ago like
you said dan and they take a video game
and they make it into real life like
they the frogs are people remember when
we used to play and there's the cars
zipping around and you got to dodge them
they got real 200 pound like foam rubber
cars and people trying to dodge and get
across them is the craziest acid trip of
a job i have ever had they said to me
dan they said imagine this this is once
in a lifetime they said here's what
we're thinking if you want to
participate in this could you call the
action like it's a football game but
make a bunch of 80s movies references
and i'm like you came to the right place
this is a dream job i couldn't be more
in and it takes you right back to the
arcade i was thinking dan of the crew
there i was trying to power rank who was
the biggest into arcade games back in
the day and they can tell me if i'm
wrong or right but i'm getting heavy
fritzy vibes i think he was on the
arcade a lot
uh probably not to play video games but
just to check out the girls uh mclevin
you strike me as a video game guy yeah i
i have some records in centipede in this
pac-man
yeah you can see ajp on some old arcade
machines in arbor
but you but you were dungeons and
dragons oh i wasn't afraid to roll a
54-sided die i'll tell you that right
now that's what mclovin's college career
was all about uh
dungeons and dragons and his and his
fake girlfriend from niagara falls uh
yes yes don't sleep on paul in the video
game department if they're if anybody
here had the collar popped on him on his
denim jacket while he was dominating
centipede it's definitely probably like
atari it sounds like yeah home and away
i would go hair parted down the middle
go to the local place in chicago heights
but at home and television big
television guy
yeah oh i was too well good luck with
frogger it's great to talk to you and uh
we'll be watching this upcoming season
with uh football morning good good
morning football uh on the nfl network
thank you kyle dan you're the best thank
you guys enjoy kyle brent co-host there
he went to princeton mclovin